it was like
y'all are talking about in cells like
School shooters what are you doing about
it I'm out there [__] them you got a
text with a male virgin how old were
that I'm not telling him you had sex
with an underage man no no you had sex
in an underage no very old much older
version on the road how old over 25. you
believed him Yes actually you [__]
idiots
for [__] years you know yeah I never
had sex before and yeah
how dare you because that's the other
thing I'm looking down the barrel of the
female comedians that like dude this
doesn't end well who does this end well
for female comedian Joan of Arc or
whatever
she's killing it so much respect that's
true but I think people love her but she
hated towards the end that she was like
doing fashion police stuff doing it like
celebrity gossip [__] I don't like to
get in don't complain about the [__] you
choose or you become gay or you become
an activist I know that's what I'm
saying no
remember when you would call me and be
like dude they totally think I give a
[__] about animals and you we would have
these do you remember that like all
giraffes oh I was not what a stupid
[__] animal I don't get if you would
call me and [__] on animals all the time
and then you'd go and make your little
videos like I gotta save a zoo a Zoo's
gonna burn in California right and you
would call me just laughing and mocking
these people remember that no I know
you need your empty guns but you do care
about animals you do care about it you
dated a veterinarian or what is going on
stop doing it you're doing it again
every time you're in a corner
that word was used a lot to control me
as a kid why do your fingers get the
bigger the Liars the second that you're
out here like this
I was used as a controlling mechanism
you said uh you loved
like what's your definition of love like
when you know you're in love with
someone
that's a good question
but I'll tell you this
do you love me
I love you
yeah but that's not in love no but in
love I'll tell you that uh
uh you at least for me I felt it in
different ways and with my wife I felt
it
no but I felt in a way I never felt with
anybody else yeah yeah and then how did
that manifest because I remember a guy
friend of mine said to me want something
like very simple second date
oh wow
second date I was like yeah I'm gonna
fall in love with this woman second day
how did you know like was it just an
energy wasn't conscious I want to listen
to everything she had to say and I want
to share everything that I had with her
and I think that was it it wasn't even
like on some like I wanted to listen to
it
a guy friend of mine who's like you know
it's a beautiful story I almost started
crying like I just wanted to listen to
it this [__] felt like a Chrysler Rose
for a second
everyone's crying for the first time in
my life I found a woman interested I
wasn't got emotional clearly that not
everybody has fallen in love yet but
it's okay
seven day hospice she was on her seventh
day of [__] home hospice this [__]
are you comparing your mom to my wife
I'm just saying the crying and the rose
there seems to be a sticking point for
everybody which is like the uh my mom
was in seven days of hospice so I'm at
[__] Kaiser Permanente which [__]
that place by the way I have umbrella
insurance I can I'm protected so I went
to Kaiser Permanente once and look how
bored he gets when it's like not just
one it's not the second date that's what
happened
like you know I care about you and I
care about your well-being and I want
everything to work out for you and uh I
would help you if you ever need anything
I mean that sincerely thank you and you
don't even trust it because so many
people have [__] you over in Life or
something like that so no I do trust it
that's not true at all I like you're I'm
very close to me what give me like Irish
boxer
no I I care about you deeply and I want
everything to work out so for me that is
love but being in love with somebody as
says Leo but happened a few times in my
life yeah and the last time was the most
profound version of it but do you feel
like that the amount of time like you
knew on the second date do you think
that you can still love someone the way
you love Emma but not know that soon
do you know what I mean like do you
think it's give me a hypothesis like for
love to happen does it have to be that
soon is my question because sometimes
I'll be with someone for like six or
seven months and I'm like do I just give
it more time I love my wife way more now
than I did on our Channel that's so cool
but there was something that happened
there was something that happened on the
second day where I was like whoa this is
different than anything I've ever
experienced has there ever been a fight
where you're like or a thing you're like
I don't know no
there's been difficulties yeah of course
but there's never been a thing where
like I don't love this person anymore
right right stop loving that was there
something that you did differently with
her where it's like with other people
like in a fight or whatever for lack of
a better word you'd be like Ah that's
[__] but with her you just like
acted differently not necessarily but I
also think it's not just I don't know I
think that
I don't feel in fights that it's over
ever right right it's about she makes me
feel there's something that she does not
in the fight outside of the fight and I
hope there's something I do outside of
the fight that makes us feel like hey
this thing sucks we need to [__] work
this out I'm being a little immature
[__] she's being immature
[__] but it doesn't feel like
it's kind of over I feel nice for me for
I think that's kind of love when you
feel like you're fighting for something
instead of fighting with someone and
you're like on the same team even though
because to me like it fights I'll
instantly be like the biggest lever just
leaving yeah but that's it so it makes
you go to that but that's like you got
to stay in the right fear but that
doesn't come from a lack of love that
comes from uh insecurity and emotional
and maturity yeah yeah I used to get
with like I love my wife so much but
when I was less mature emotionally there
were 5B fights where I'd be like I don't
know if this is worth it and now and I
think you'll know when you're in love
because when you're in love you're like
this sucks yeah let's just do this we're
gonna deal with this it's gonna be okay
yeah but don't Define the Love by the
fights yeah I think that's the biggest
well I guess for me it's like I always
thought like love it's not about what
it's like when things are going well
it's about when things are hard you know
it's like about when it's going well
like how much fun is it when it's going
well that's what I think keeps you
together I guess I just haven't had a
fun life yet like I I also was people
like give intimacy issues you don't want
to be someone's like I didn't want to be
with someone when I had a mom hanging
off of a thing like I was engaged uh to
a guy Madoff Raya awesome dude and when
we started planning the wedding I just
couldn't like you know picture my mom in
a wheelchair and like who was gonna walk
me down the aisle like I just couldn't
yeah you know so now that she's dead I
feel like I can I understand what you
mean now when you say either you feel
free
it's just like there's a point where you
realize like in my my mother's daughter
am I my own person and I guess I never
got to be my own person just because I
was in the shadow of her illness I think
you suffer from
uh
uh being too smart sometimes where I
think that you can like intellectualize
every aspect of your behavior and find a
justification for it somewhere I think
that's what we do as stand-ups but when
you turn on yourself like were these you
know analysts like you almost need to be
able to shut your brain off and just be
you know to quote liver King Primal for
a second I'm trying dude dude I'm doing
two Hobbies now I'm taking on two
hobbies that I'm not allowed to turn
into businesses awesome example because
like you're trying so hard to just be a
human it's [__] and like you're like
I'm gonna have a hobby no by the way
other one because I also became a comic
like I knew I was like growing up like
but being a comic is your most authentic
State I genuinely mean that yeah like I
think being a person is way harder for
you that's what you are you're a comic
you're making people laugh you're like
literally getting people drinking this
is you this is you being in this kind of
manic State making things funny like
roasting having great ideas putting them
together steps ahead you always have to
have nine backup plans for jokes but
what makes you so good at this is what
makes life so difficult and also growing
up with uh in an alcoholic home like if
you're scattered they're scatterbrained
so me being all over the place like is
linear to them same I grew up in an
alcoholic house and there's a lot of
Peace making and just making sure
everybody's oh yeah like and then that's
just not
you have to be alien like narcissists
you have to like you know and then also
defining your self or your productivity
and usefulness to others and like
entertaining people and like and then as
you get older it's just like annoying
like you're just the annoying people
pleaser who like won't turn off you know
kind of thing but I think yeah it's
weird because I got on the TV I remember
as a kid going like I have to get in the
box like I saw happy families in the box
and I was like your family value what
was in the Box well yeah well my dad
like they would watch TV
usually comes but I would commercials is
what I wanted though I would I didn't
want to be in movies I want to be in
commercials because that's interesting
that's where the happy families were I
was like I gotta get there dude that's
where the [__] food is on the dinner
table everybody's happy dude the fridge
is like how do I get in there I would
literally drive by like on um like uh
whatever family trips and there'd be
like an exit for a McDonald's let's get
off at McDonald's all I would see is
like how did that why is that kid eating
the fries can I be honest with you yeah
I think that there's a perfect example
of you intellectualizing a situation but
that's not the real reason I think that
your dad watched that TV and that was
the most important thing how do I get
his attention and I need to get in there
to get his attention his validation and
that is often what children do the only
reason I started boxing or enjoy boxing
or did a boxing I did a boxing match is
because I knew how much my Dad loved
boxing my dad gave me all the validation
and even with all the validation from my
dad I maybe this would impress him even
more and he was so impressed and it felt
so good so it's like we we
subconsciously are drawn to the things
that our parents really care about even
if we resent our parents we still want
their value we shouldn't because it's
equate like a reptilian right see how
smart you are you're like you created
this perfect beautiful story of like
there's a family eating McDonald's and I
want that
no you don't no you would have been a
commercial actress if you did but you
created great shows a commercial to save
my life they oh I went and they always
said I sounded sarcastic try tied with
bleach the best for your time McDonald's
it's super good yeah
I know they always said I was too
sarcastic your dad would change the
channel and you're like come on I
finally got in it's also like the jury's
still out if I'm the progressive lady or
not so maybe I am in commercials
but it's wild though because I was like
that's where the love is your lesbian
and trans fat you are the progressive
[Laughter]
should I take a Prozac before I go in I
was also on Prozac and I just like went
off at like willy-nilly yeah I was like
I don't want to be on any of this farmer
[__] I've also been like under the
influence of like Pharma birth control
so how do you get so a person like you
you know usually smarter than most of
the people around you right I mean let's
just assume right it's hard to take
advice from people around you if you're
like I don't know if these people are
smarter than me probably most people
around you you're more successful than
it's like why don't I take advice from
any of these [__] but what
happens if those people have good advice
that would help you reflect on your life
and maybe make your life easier yeah
would you push them away or would you be
willing to digest it I think it depends
I think when someone's giving you advice
you can usually tell if they're like
authentic yeah if they really are trying
to solve the problem or like show off or
project it seems like sometimes the
people with their lives that are the
most disarray are the ones that want to
give the most advice yeah just sort of
like like someone that's trying to
control you or they want to you to like
owe them in some way you know I think
we're in this sort of like as a species
like everyone's an expert in everything
now and I read this this book and I
watched this Ted talk and you're like
can you just tell me what you think I
should do like I don't need you to quote
nine fake experts